hi Yin thanks a lot for joining us today
thank you for inviting me I drink I'm
glad to be here yeah one of the world's
most visible deep learning researchers
let us share bit about your personal
story so how do you end up doing this
work that you now do yeah that sounds
great I guess I first became interested
in machine learning
right before I met you actually I had
been working on neuroscience and my
undergraduate advisor
Jerry cane at Stanford encouraged me to
take your intro to AI class well I
didn't know that okay so I had always
thought that AI was a good idea but that
in practice the main thing I knew that
was happening was like game AI I said
where people have a lot of hard-coded
rules for non player characters and
games to say different scripted lines at
different points in time and then when I
took your intro to a high class and you
covered topics like linear regression
and the bias and various variance
decomposition of the error of linear
regression I started to realize that
this was a real science and I could
actually have a scientific career in a
guy rather than neuroscience see great
and then what happened well I came back
into ITA two-year course not later seen
right so the really big turning point
for me was while I was teeing that
course one of the students my friend
Ethan Dreyfus got interested in Jeff
Shannon's deep belief that paper and the
two of us ended up building one of the
first GPU CUDA based machines at
Stanford in order to run bolts and
machines in our spare time of her winter
break and at that point I started to
have a very strong intuition that deep
learning was the way to go in the future
that a lot of the other girls I was
working with like support vector
machines didn't seem to have the right
asymptotics that you add more training
data and they get slower or for the same
amount of training data it's hard to
make them perform a lot better by
changing other settings at that point I
I started to focus on deep learning as
much as possible in the and
remember Magette rayna's very odd GPU
paper right acknowledges you for having
done laudatory work yeah yeah that was
written using some of the machines that
we built the first machine I built was
just something that Ethan and I built
that Ethan's mom's house with I see wait
with our own money and then later we
have money to build the first to agree
for the Stanford lab wow that's great I
never knew that story that's great yeah
um and then today one of the you know
things that's really taken the deep
learning world by storm is your
invention of Gans so how did you come up
with that I'd been studying generative
models for a long time so it ganzar a
way of giving generative modeling where
you have a lot of training data and
you'd like to learn to produce more
examples that resemble the training data
but but they're imaginary they've never
been seen exactly in that form before
there were several other ways of doing
generative models that had been popular
for several years before I had the idea
for against and after I've been working
on all those other methods throughout
most of my PhD I knew a lot about the
advantages and disadvantages of all the
other frameworks like bulletin machines
and sparse coding and all the other
approaches that had been really popular
for years I was looking for something
how to avoid all of those disadvantages
at the same time and then finally when I
was arguing about derided models with my
friends in a bar something clicked into
place and I started telling them you
need to do this this and this and I
swear it'll work and my my friends
didn't believe me that it would work I
was supposed to be writing the deep
learning textbook at the time but I
believed strongly enough that it would
work that I went home and coded it up
the same night and it worked
so thank you one evening to implement
the first version as a if I implemented
it around midnight after going home from
the bar where my friend had his
going-away party I see and the first
version of it worked which is very very
fortunate I didn't have to search for
hyper parameters meaning there was a
story I read it somewhere where you had
a near-death experience and that
reaffirm your commitment to AI and tell
me that so
yeah I wasn't actually near death but I
briefly thought that I was I had a very
bad headache and some of the doctors
thought that I might have a burping
hemorrhage and during the time that I
was waiting for my MRI results to find
out whether I had a brain hemorrhage or
not I realized that most of the thoughts
I was having were about making sure that
other people would eventually try out
the research ideas that I had at the
time
in retrospect they're all pretty silly
research ideas but I at that point I
realized that this was actually one of
my highest priorities in life was
carrying out my machine learning
research work I see yeah that's great
that when you thought you might be dying
soon you're just thinking how do we get
the research done yeah yeah
that that does commitment yeah so today
you're still at the center of a lot of
the activities with Gans with
regenerative adversarial networks so
tell me how you see the future of guns
right now guns are used for a lot of
different things like so my supervised
learning generating training data for
other models and even simulating
scientific experiments in principle all
of these things could be done by other
kinds of generative models so I think
that games are at an important
crossroads right now right now they work
well some of the time but it can be more
of an art than a science to really bring
that performance out of them that's more
or less how people felt about deep
learning in general ten years ago and
back then we were using deep belief
networks with bullets and machines as
the building blocks they were very very
finicky over time we switched to things
like rectified linear units and batch
normalization and deep learning became a
lot more reliable if we can make guns
become as reliable as deep learning has
become but I think we'll keep seeing
guns used in all the places are used
today with much greater success if we
aren't able to figure out how to
stabilize guns that I think their main
contribution to the history of deep
learning is that they will have shown
people how to do all these tasks that
involve generative model
and eventually we will replace them with
other forms of generative models so I
spend maybe about 40% of my time right
now working on stabilizing kids
I see cool oh and some so just as a lot
of people they joined deep learning
about 10 years ago such as yourself
ended up being pioneers maybe the people
they joined Gans today if it works out
could end up the early pioneers yeah a
lot of people already are early pioneers
of Gans
and I think if you wanted to give any
kind of history of again so far you'd
really need to mention other groups like
indigo and Facebook and Berkeley for all
the different things that they've done
so in addition to all your research you
also co-authored a book on deep learning
oh is that good that's right with Joshua
Benji oh and Aaron kohrville who were my
PhD co advisors we wrote the first
textbook on the modern version of deep
learning and that has been very popular
both in the English edition of the
Chinese edition we've sold about I think
around 70,000 copies total between those
two languages and I've had a lot of
feedback from students who say that
they've learned a lot from it one thing
that we did a little bit differently
than some other books is we start with a
very focused introduction to the kind of
math that you need to do deep learning I
think one thing that I got from your
courses at Stanford is the linear
algebra and probability are very
important that people get excited about
the machine learning algorithms but if
you want to be a really excellent
practitioner you've got to master the
basic math of underlies the whole
approach in the first place so we make
sure to give a very focused presentation
of the math basics at the start of the
book that way you don't need to go ahead
and learn all of linear algebra but you
can get a very quick crash course in the
pieces of linear algebra that are the
most useful for deep learning so you
even someone who's math you know is a
little shaky you haven't seen an app for
yes we're gonna start from the beginning
of your book and get that background and
get into designing all of the facts that
you would need to know are there it
would definitely take some focused
effort and practice at making use of
them if someone's really afraid of
method it might be a bit of a painful
experience but but if you're ready for
the learning experience and you believe
you can master it I think all the all
the tools that you need are there as
someone this worked in deep learning for
a long time I'd be curious if you look
back over the years tell me about how
about how you're thinking of AI and of
deep learning has evolved over the years
ten years ago I felt like as a community
the biggest challenge in machine
learning was just how to get it working
for AI related tasks at all we had
really good tools that we can use for
simpler tasks where we wanted to
recognize patterns in hand extracted
features where a human designer could do
a lot of the work by creating those
features and then hand it off to the
computer and that was really good for
different things like predicting which
adds a user would click on or different
kinds of basic scientific analysis but
we really struggled to do anything
involving millions of pixels in an image
or a raw audio waveform where the system
had to build all of its understanding
from scratch we finally got over the
hurdle really thoroughly maybe five
years ago and now we're at a point where
there are so many different paths open
that someone who wants to get involved
in AI maybe the hardest problem they
faced is choosing which path they want
to go down do you want to make
reinforcement learning work as well as
supervised learning works do you want to
make unsupervised learning work as well
as supervised learning works do you want
to make sure that machine learning
algorithms are fair and reflect biases
that we
fer to avoid do you want to make sure
that the societal issues surrounding AI
work out well that we are able to make
sure that nei benefits everyone rather
than causing social upheaval and and
trouble with loss of jobs I think right
now there's just really an amazing
amount of different things that can be
done both to prevent downsides from AI
but also to make sure that we leverage
all of the upsides that it offers us and
so today there are a lot of people
wanting to get into AI so what advice
would you have for someone like that I
think a lot of people that want to get
into AI start thinking that they
absolutely need to get a PhD or some
other kind of credential like that I
don't think that's actually a
requirement anymore one way that you
could get a lot of attention is to write
good code and put it on github if you
have an interesting project that solves
a problem that someone working at a top
lab wanted to solve once they find your
github repository they'll come find you
and ask you to come work there a lot of
the people that I've I've hired or
recruited at opening I last year or at
Google this year I first became
interested in working with them because
of something that I saw that they
released in open-source form on the
internet writing papers and putting them
on archive can also be good a lot of the
time it's harder to reach the point
where you have something polished enough
to really be a new academic contribution
to the scientific literature but you can
often get to the point of having a
useful software product much earlier so
sort of you know meet your book practice
and materials and pulls on github and
maybe on archive I think if you if you
learn by reading the book it's really
important to also work on a project at
the same time to either choose some way
of applying machine learning to an area
that you're already interested in like
if you're a field biologist and you want
to get into deep learning maybe you
use it to identify birds or if you don't
have an idea for how you'd like to use
machine learning in your own life you
could pick something like making a
Street View house numbers classifier
where all the data sets are set up to
make it very straightforward for you
that way you get to exercise all of the
basic skills while you read the book or
while you watch Coursera videos that
explain the concepts to you so over the
last couple years have also seen you do
one more work on abbis arrow examples
tell us a bit about that yeah I think
adversarial examples are the beginning
of a new field that I called machine
learning security in the past we've seen
computer security issues where attackers
could fool a computer into running the
wrong code that's called application
level security and there's been attacks
where people can fool a computer into
believing that messages on a network
come from somebody that is not actually
who they says they say they are and
that's called Network level security now
we're starting to see that you can also
fool machine learning algorithms into
doing things they shouldn't even if the
program running the machine learning
algorithm is running the correct code
even if the program running the machine
learning algorithm and those who all the
messages on the network really came from
and I think it's important to build
security into any new technology near
the start of its development we've found
that it's very hard to build a working
system first and then add security later
so I am really excited about the idea
that if we dive in and start
anticipating security problems with
machine learning now we can make sure
that these algorithms are secure from
the start instead of trying to patch it
and richer actively years later thank
you that was great there's a lot about
your story that I thought was
fascinating in that despite having known
you for years I didn't actually know so
thank you for sharing all that oh very
welcome thank you for inviting me
there was a great chat Thanks